we have a tweet from George I don't know
you George but uh you have this tweet
breaking Trump crowd chance vpv PVP
after V gets done speaking Trump says
he's going to be working with us for a
long time here's the video clip let's
play it for you right
[Applause]
now good to see
you thank you thank you wow that's how
was that pretty good right that was
pretty good and he's a fantastic guy and
he's really uh he's got something that's
very special because he started off with
the Zippo and he's got he ended up very
strong he did a great job I was actually
surprised when he called because he was
doing well and it's an honor to have his
endorsement he's going to be working
with us and he'll be working with us for
a long time he's going to be working
with us for a long time because uh we we
were talking about this a little bit
before the show V needs to work in a
trump Administration if he's going to be
the next guy after Trump and I think he
can be he needs government experience
one of the one of the pitfalls one of
the reasons why V was not the guy this
time around Trump had that first term he
walked to the Minefield he hit some of
these mines he knows where some of them
are he can do a better job this time
around perfect no good yes VI good
speaker good ideas great ideas in fact
but it or those landmines land landmines
aren't the same way Trump does so if
aake gets a position in the Trump
Administration then coming into 2027 he
begins campaigning he will have the
experience behind him and I got to tell
you man Trump is this unrefined or and V
is refined when When Donald Trump
explains something it works for the
average person and he's he's this Brash
crash guy who's going to say it like it
is the V can lay it out analytically and
just he can say sell it to you so I
think this team up I don't know to what
extent what do you guys think you think
he's VP I think that would be great what
do you think Adam I don't think he's VP
he's just too big of a personality I
think he's a cabinet secretary because
cabinet secretary your name will be
constantly in the news you can go on TV
all the time you can create policy you
could you could be you know be ready
prepared for
2028 VP I think he needs someone like
Trump needs someone like a Tim Scott a
more calmer Carson
Scott sorry the alpha that Trump is and
I feel like Vivic is an alpha but more
refined like you said would just be too
much together it's just you can't put
two electric like Outlets you can't put
two positive together would just spark
too much right you can't do that yeah
Secretary of State what do you think
Secretary of Energy Secretary of
Commerce maybe Chief maybe uh you know
Chief staff but person might be too big
for Chief of Staff just he needs a
front- facing position cuz he's so good
on camera he's really Charming he can
really communicate a message think about
him on TV every week Meet the Press or
you know National talking about Economic
Policy run circles around these people
someone like a blank great yeah you want
him to be frontf facing for sure um I
you know I take him seriously when he
came on this show and said that he
didn't want to be VP and I think Tim's
right that having more experience in the
government would be good and in some
ways VPS
aren't super known for what they
contribute to to uh an Administration
there's a rumor that it'll be Doug B
because based on what Trump said last
night beram was back was with him there
he ended him didn't he he endorsed him
and last night when Trump was giving his
remarks he said something like oh he's
gonna he's gonna be around like he had
this like smirk and St burum 2024 and no
one will see that coming I think that's
sort of I think he needs a you know he
but he needs a personality that's
quieter than thees and bergham is
quieter than totally disagree he had Mr
quiet personality and stupid Pence and
that didn't work out I think he should
go for someone nice and big gab Tulsi I
like Tulsi I like Tucker I like anybody
who can go out there and rev up a crowd
almost as good as Trump does because
also he's going to need somebody on the
campaign Trail while he's being dragged
around by you know stupid Merrick
Garland and his minions yeah I would
love to see Trump just put a candy bar
on Merrick Garland's head so funny again
it was one of the best moments I think
that there are a lot of potentially good
picks I think Bergen would be weird
because North Dakota is not you know
necessarily a stronghold I guess it's
it's different um but the way he was
talking about him there is there is a
belief that buram is involved somehow so
you could start piecing together who his
cabinet to be my question with vake and
you know it could be great for him to
gain experience on the federal level and
then potentially run again in
2028 I wish that he would take some of
the really Innovative things that he
talked about like Civic engagement and
and different things during his campaign
and apply it on a small scale in in Ohio
it's just that the timing doesn't line
up where he could take a position in
Ohio and then run again in 2028 from
what from what I
know I don't know berham does not seem
like VP that that's that that you might
as well put just Trump blank yeah that's
what I don't want I don't mean to be
these cherry picking like Democrats but
I don't think we need a white male from
North Dakota that get help with the
ticket I maybe I like the old way where
you just get the second guy you know
what I mean oh so Biden no s STIs yeah
the old way was whoever got second place
in the general would be the vice
president yeah that's how you um Adams
the the the argument there was that the
country would have representation for
those who lost the election and it makes
sense now it's not so half the country
feels disenfranchised you know very
articulate doing a great job out of New
York Alise the stonic the Congress has
done a good job excellent speaker she
went to Harvard she's real
F I don't see VP there though TOS toy
gabard is a long shot but you kind of
make sense if people when people say it
you're like okay I can kind of
understand why she'd be VP um people are
saying Christy Nome yeah she kind of
feels like VP and she's been a trump
Ally for a really long time with
stepanic I wouldn't want to lose her
from Congress I think she's doing really
good things and it's nice to see that
representation in New York I mean part
of part of the problem is that if you
lift anyone out of position they're
currently in that becomes a vacuum you
don't know where what's going to fill it
I got it Trump trump 2024 which one
Baron Don yes Junior Don Junior ER don
junr don junr yeah but then the
Democrats would freak out and be like
he's just putting his own kids in this
is crazy he's a George Bush just like
and the Adams is yeah it's Don junor is
great uh but I can understand why he's a
family member they wouldn't do it but I
think Don Jr would be a great choice too
do you think he'd run for office on his
own though I mean would he run for state
or you know senate or something like
that I don't think I I don't know if Don
Junior's gonna go that
route I I don't know I don't see it I
think he could be a VP but I think the
play is to get someone outside of the
Trump space that's why chrisye ome makes
sense tulsey gabard could make sense but
it definitely seems like a 0.1%
likelihood you know I like telsey gabard
uh asvp because you know military
experience fairly moderate could attract
former Democrats and disaffected
liberals she would also do some work
right I mean KLA Harris doesn't do
anything at all telsey gabard would be
like I have a position I'm going to do
some stuff KLA Harris entertains us
every day with her vep style speeches
she's unburdened by what might have been
man it is amazing when she says stuff
like how does she keep is a good thing
because it's the community it's like and
you're like what what well and the Biden
Administration initially they had her
out there they moved her to the
background and now that we're getting
closer to 2024 they're kind of being
like it's the Biden Harris
Administration they really are trying to
sell that and it's for the middle two
years they were like stand in the back
and don't say anything because she was
just not good right well they were
trying to get her to do stuff and she
wouldn't do it remember the whole
borders are and then her office was like
no no she's not the borders are she's
working on the root causes of migration
in the northern triangle countries and
she's not even doing that and then she
was like actually it's
lgbtqia a plus violence that is the
problem so we need to prioritize them
for Asylum which then they had an EO
about that that's have have you guys
seen that Meme where it's
lgbtq plus and it's let's get Biden to
quit plus Kamala that very smun very
funny people the internet is undefeated
I mean I wish we could pick VP based on
like what issue they are going to
rabidly Champion during the
administration because then I would love
to see you know really serious uh
immigration restrictionists go into
office but I just don't think that's
going to happen so much of the VP
selection is saying who can we Court in
terms of um Electoral College votes and
where where's RFK junor here is he still
around he was in North Carolina over the
weekend aad was there covering him and
he has an event in West Virginia coming
up I think he's doing pretty well for an
independent but you know he's not it's
sort of hard because he's not in the
news cycle because there's no primary
for the independent he's like either
just going to it or not but he's also I
don't think he's taking the like V went
from zero with like in a year look at
this he went to to fourth place in the
primary he went to 8% in the Iowa caucus
I mean this is amazing and he did it and
and and even you know got the Trump Camp
worried because he was getting so much
support but he went around the Press
circuit he went to podcasters media
personalities and he and he made himself
available to them RFK is not doing that
so much he has an opportunity to get
attention he won't take it and that 8%
he took it took it right from Trump
those are all Trump voters well actually
technically yes well maybe he grew the
pie with young people he did that's what
it is uh so 30 so among firsttime voters
V was in first place and uh Ronda sis
actually according to one poll got more
gen Z than any other candidate but uh V
got a good amount of trump supporters
but a lot of firsttime Voters so that's
I think that's the opportunity here for
Trump the targeting new voters brilliant
because now he goes to the Trump camp
and says I didn't think I was going to
be able to pull it off I didn't pull it
off you got my endorsement I can bring
in new voters for you and get those
numbers up I'm going to pull in voters
from areas you've never seen before yeah
that'd be cool and I think that's a good
sign for you know conservative values or
maybe libertarian vales generally
because they were really drawn to to uh
RAM Swami's campaign and ultimately
that's the future right some it's easy
to focus on what happens this November
but what we want long term is for new
voters to be interested in voting for
candidates represent long-term
investment in a future that's going to
be steady and provide a prosperous life
for a lot of people well part of the
problem with that is that we have no
shared vision of either America's future
or of America's past yeah we have no
real social cohesion or vision for what
the American character is or
understanding of where we came from it's
just a a constant fracturing but when do
you think the fracture started do you
have a an
estimate this is something that is you
know that has recently been coming up I
was actually talking to um inz stepman
today about it on her podcast high noon
uh something I've been talking to Jack
pic about he's been talking about
leftist revolutions and it was actually
really fascinating he had this series on
human events daily during the um period
between Christmas and New Year's and it
was like four I think it was four
episodes about cultural revolutions or
like leftist revolutions and it was
uh I forget what they all were but there
were a bunch of them and they were
really fascinating but the one that I
found Most Fascinating was the one about
the 1960s in America the cultural
revolution in America which I had never
conceived of as a
revolution I never conceived of it as a
leftist revolution you know to a certain
extent I just thought of it as you know
my stupid parents were they're not
stupid I love you guys mom and dad your
silly parents my parents were sort of
part of the whole hippie thing they were
Boomers they came of age during that
period I thought you know it just it
seemed like a very cultural moment and
it was something where you know fashion
would take from it as I was growing up
it was always like now we're in the 60s
moment again now we're in it again now
we're in it again um but I never thought
of it as a revolution and I've been
thinking about that uh
a lot and then you know the civil rights
movement and that whole era which I
always had a very I thought I had a very
clear view of it and I've been
reconsidering it um but I think that a
lot of it started then when you had this
huge generation of young people saying
to their parents everything you taught
us was wrong everything you thought
about the country is Wrong everything
you think about us and our future is
wrong we're going to destroy everything
you built we're going to dance around in
that rubble and we're going to build on
top of rubble and I think that's what
happened so then when you hit the '90s
which in my view like I was in my 20s I
guess in the 90s um you hit the 90s when
you had a very what what seemed to me a
colorblind Society you had a lot of
great culture um that was like you know
I was hanging out with a bunch of Art
Kids downtown New York City and there
was just money everywhere it's like
you'd go out and like somebody would
pick up the tab it somebody would you
know somebody would fund the giant art
show there was money left over who even
knows who even knows what was going on
um but you know it seemed like this
Pinnacle of civilization but it was
really
apparently just built on top of rubble
you know the rubble of our
grandparents of our religion of our
culture of our shared past of our
appreciation for our history I grew up
in a small town on Long Island Port jef
Station and my neighbors were
African-American black but never had
discussions about race never had
discussions about any of this and we
were just my neighbor and we we liked
each other and got along well saying all
along my life I had black friends never
thought of it I think somewhere along
the line when Obama got elected at the
very beginning of his term there was
this uh you know incident at Harvard
University with this black professor
right off the bat and the police called
because he was being obnoxious he was
screaming something about
right off the bat the president of the
United States took the side of the
obnoxious Professor that's right and
went against the white police officers
and it became a race issue when it had
nothing to do with race and the media
jumped on this and said they need a
lesson the police need to go to you know
sensitivity training and I think
somewhere that incident I feel like
stood out really in this lesson where
Obama wanted to turn back the clock on
race relations and I feel like that's
kind of like was the start of didn't he
have had a beer Summit for what because
a guy was being obnoxious and he had to
accuse the white police officers thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net